you need to be insane insane about
output number one
the game is back at scale short form
content Joe was throwing out to be you
know my podcast I've done for four and a
half years I do my Friday five minute
Friday I've done I did my blog I mean
I'm just throwing out tons of content
but Joe told me about two weeks ago
short form vertical 60 seconds or last
YouTube two three four times a day I
started throwing it out my question for
you is on across YouTube oh it's not
YouTube across my podcast this video
with audio my videos posted on YouTube
My audio's thrown up on in full form in
full form yeah you know full form but
like the quick so both the whole thing
and then the post-production so I got
the video and I got the audio videos on
YouTube the audio is hosted on Buzz
Sprout which then goes out to all the
platforms yep
I get a sense like the video
isn't getting me the traction that the
audio did okay like audio only so when I
posted when I throw it out there on IG
LinkedIn or whatever I'm throwing my
stuff would you post the video which
gives you that beautiful thumbnail and
then here's the audio only version which
is what I've been doing or do you say
screw the video side of it like YouTube
search handle that and I just throw out
the audiooli version which was good for
me for a while remember I'm in a small
pond so that's question one well that's
that there's a lot there first of all
the first answer is both
you literally post them both
you literally Post in big letters Audio
Only and then you post the next six
hours later with the video in your video
video like you do not the same post the
same post but you can because you said
six hours later yeah the same well one's
the you said should I put out the audio
or should I put out the video I'm
putting a vote I'm putting the video
which gives me the thumbnail and in that
post here's the audio only version yeah
I understand okay yeah that's exactly
and by the way you don't need to put the
link to the video because you could just
take a screenshot from any moment you
liked and then just post the audio link
so he's saying you can have a hero image
correct
but I think you you subconsciously or
consciously got to the more important
part of course it worked more up front
you were just getting your penetration
to your pond that you know you were just
starting to fish this new Pond you've
eaten a lot of [__] fish out of that
pond and because your thing is so narrow
which is great because I love narrow
depth well there's only so many fish in
there right right
so now what ends up happening is you've
got to start creating micro strategies
for example
what is the content you're making for
the kids that are in school to become
Ortho right right that's going to be
very different content than someone
who's 17 years into their career and is
trying to maximize their profits or
their lifestyle or are transitioning so
what you've got to now do is
micro segment the pond
right right which is what I started
doing good I really started focusing
much more on the residents because my
demo is orthos or out of school
you know a year to 12 years give or take
ages 30 to 42 43s that's like my demo
yep but most people don't realize the
average orthodontist is coming out of
residency with five six eight hundred
thousand in debt yeah right and so
getting them ahead of the curve and
going okay guys you guys get into school
soon let me teach you how to hit the
ground running let me show you like I
know what you're living and what you yes
comma what you could also start doing
and this is where you can widen your
world you could be talking to them while
they're in the process of collecting the
debt and what could they potentially be
doing right and that's where the
narrative is sort of Switched at this
point in the game and then again the
last question is again I don't want to
take too much time this isn't the big
problem but it's hard do I chase like
when I talk to orthodontists about I
could talk to anybody in this room about
it's the same stuff you talk about 100
the culture the hustle the the plan
right the the team you should absolutely
start flirting with broader our content
100 it needs to be part of your mix it's
hard you know to serve both Masters but
are you kidding me the first 50 pieces
of business content I made every comment
was [__] you stay in your lane wine boy
what the [__] do you know about business
I'm like Jesus Christ I was like that's
all I've been doing I just became Wine
Guy to you because of YouTube I'm like I
am business you know so you yeah you'll
get some of that you'll probably less
because it's not as big of a jump for
you because you've been talking about
the business support though
um you should absolutely my shorts have
been focused on but you need to be
insane insane about Facebook fan page
output number one
the game is back at scale and that's
where I live so Facebook fan page number
one YouTube shorts number two Tick Tock
number three you must dominate those
three arbitrages how many pieces of
content like a day would you say ideal
for per platform
yeah
on those and then there's Twitter and
Instagram and regular YouTube and Link
and Linkedin so I can do content
creation that's what I love doing and
content creation is more about
post-production than actually your time
it really is if I've got if I've got
which again I'm working purposely to
make sure that I've got those moments
those times where you can take pieces
and show them out later on that's right
like you talk about it right 100 and
close every time that's right right and
so um the the last little one which it
may not be that little but I I don't
think it's huge is it's been on my mind
for at least three years now
um and listening to you talk a lot about
the culture the social consciousness of
a company I feel like I have to do this
like this is like keep me up at night
but I'm afraid of the resources it's
going to take is I've been trying for
three years in my head should create
something called embracing our Warriors
where too many PTSD injured hurt vets
come back and the VA doesn't take care
of them they want they deserve a smile
they deserve to feel good when they look
in the mirror and I've been talking to
the VA I've been talking to the
non-profit folks about developing
because I've got the sponsors or
companies that create Ortho Brands I've
got the doctors all over the country
that's right
um to be able to develop this non-profit
where a vet can be vetted like legit
like they are disabled vet and them and
their family can find a dock that we
hook them up with who will get free
product from a company so just uh just
crawl
just get it started
yeah you know when you're winning
in one part it makes a lot of sense
because you're playing at this scale
over here that it feels natural to get
this thing over here to be at that same
scale immediately
and I think you know the resources is a
real thing but I think what you do is
you just decide today that you're going
to do it for 25 people you're gonna
Alpha test it out with a brand or brands
with a couple of Doc like a doctors or
when you get the applicants you'll just
bubble gum and tape it one by one you'll
call Ronnie or Sally and be like this
guy's in Minnesota will you do like you
just Alpha it I got the contacts just
hey yeah because what you're trying to
do rightfully I get it you're trying to
come from here and push it down like
here's the platform this is what we do
and then you're boiling the ocean
and this is what you get into this
moment instead do it behind the scenes
as bubble gum and tape get the taste of
it and then scale it right on yeah I can
do it from within it's the biggest
reason content doesn't work I alluded to
it when I was talking about a show can
just be clicked but everybody everybody
it's the biggest mistake is they try to
make it too big and it's all in their
head and they never do anything
it just go this way yeah just start
doing the best way to do it is when you
call 25 of my friends tell them to post
in their communities hey anybody know
anybody that's right and then I connect
them to sponsors and get it done you've
got a big enough platform that you just
say here's the Google for you make one
Google form you make one video you send
people and then you see what state
they're in and then you reach out to the
people you wear traffic control because
then you're more in control great idea
thanks you got it so here's the big one
and I brought this one legitimately it
doesn't I work with a guy Todd Brown uh
it was really brilliant guy helped us a
lot but it's awesome I don't know if you
know Todd or heard of it that's awesome
offers that's good
nobody can solve this so I've got a
group called orthopreneurs Rd at
Regional dominant stupid name I made it
five years ago but nonetheless it's a
group of about 195 dogs Google and Nike
are stupid names
why are they not names are just proxies
names are made so garyvee with two
silent E's is a stupid name on the
record two silent E's is a bad idea
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]